[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
eines meiner lieblings rezepte denn als
schoko verstehe ich total auf diese
schokoladen tat eine tat besteht aus
einem mürbeteig und einer füllung und in
meinem fall ist es ein richtig leckeren
schoko mittag mit einer extrem
intensiven schokoladen füllung
[Musik]
wir beginnen zuallererst mit dem mit
teig und dafür benötigen wir mehr pro
tag die es kalt und die habe ich bereits
in kleine stücke geschnitten außerdem
bei kakao zucker und etwas salz
für den teig verwende ich jetzt meine
küchenmaschine das ganze funktioniert
aber auch wunderbar mit den händen
nun gebe ich zu allererst die kalte
butter zusammen mit dem zucker und dem
salz in die röhre schüsse und lasst das
etwa eine minute geschmeidig kneten
anschließend geben wir dass ein mit dazu
und rühren das so lange unter bis es
sich mit dem restlichen teig verbunden
hat
[Musik]
nun kommen auch schon die trockenen
zutaten mit dazu also einfach das mehl
und das backpulver mit in die schüssel
geben und noch mal rühren lassen
[Musik]
das ganze braucht dann auch gar nicht
lange sobald sich die zutaten
miteinander verbunden haben nehmen wir
sie aus der schüssel und machen auf der
arbeitsfläche weiter
hier seht ihr auch die küchenmaschine
kann manchmal nicht weiterhelfen
deshalb machen wir den rest jetzt mit
unseren hinten und kneten das ganze so
lange bis sich auch die butter stücke
gelöst haben und ihr einen einheitlichen
geschmeidigen teig erhalten habt
etwa ein drittel des teiges gebe ich mir
jetzt an die seite und nehme mir zwei
drittel des tages um den boden einer
springform auszulegen dem boden habe ich
hier noch mal zusätzlich mit backpapier
ausgekleidet das hilft mir immer ganz
gut um den kuchen später zu lösen und
wer eine tat form hat der kann
selbstverständlich an der stelle auch
die tat form benutzen
sobald dann der boden der springform mit
dem teig ausgelegt wurde geht es an den
rand der springform mir persönlich hilft
es immer wenn ich den übrig gebliebenen
mit teig zu einem strang rolle und den
dann an den rand meiner springform lege
um ihn anschließend an zu drücken
[Musik]
ihr müsst das auch nicht in einem
schwung erledigen ihr könnt natürlich
auch mehrere kleine strenge machen und
euch langsam voran tasten
[Musik]
anschließend nehmt ihr euch dann zum
beispiel ein marzipan messer also nimmt
ja auch kein scharfes damit ihr euch
eure springform nicht ruiniert und
schneidet dann am rand entlang gerade
den teig ab ok ja ich gebe es zu
bei mir ist das auch nicht ganz so
gerade allerdings muss ich zu meiner
verteidigung sagen ich habe gar nicht
gesehen was ich da überhaupt schneide
denn die kamera war auf der anderen
seite und ich durfte gar nicht so
wirklich gucken ihr kriegt das besser
hin da bin ich mir sicher
und dann nehmt ihr euch den restlichen
teig und verteilt das auf die leeren
stellen um die lücken auszufüllen
sobald dann euer möglich schön in eurer
springform verteilt wurde stechen wir
mit der gabel an der oberfläche ein also
nicht am rand sondern nur an der
oberfläche
damit beim backen auch nicht hochgeht
nun muss der mürbeteig für mindestens 30
minuten in den kühlschrank damit ja auch
schön fest wird und nach dem backen noch
richtig gut in form bleibt nach etwa 30
minuten ist der teig schon viel fester
und er kommt zum vor backen in den ofen
bei 190 grad ober und unterhitze für 15
minuten
falls er dann nach dem backen doch ein
wenig hoch gegangen sein sollte an
einigen stellen denn das ist nicht ganz
unüblich dann drückt ihr das ganze
einfach runter frisch nach dem backen
ist es auch noch möglich ohne dass ihr
euch zerbricht
ihr braucht auch keine winkel palette es
geht auch zum beispiel ein einfaches
glas für die schokofüllung benötigen wir
tat bitter kuvertüre butter außerdem
eier zucker und sahne
des weiteren starken kaffee oder
espresso und vanille extrakt oder
vanille zucker
so jetzt geht es weiter auf dem herd und
hier werden zuallererst sahne und butter
zum kochen gebracht und anschließend
geben wir die klein gehackte kuvertüre
mit hinein
[Musik]
der herd kann auch schon ausgeschaltet
werden und sobald die kuvertüre in der
heißen sonne geschmolzen ist und sich
alles miteinander verbunden hat lassen
wir das für zehn minuten an der seite
stehen
nach etwa zehn minuten ist das ganze ein
wenig herunter gekühlt und wir geben die
restlichen zutaten mit hinein an der
stelle gebe ich mein espresso mit dazu
und wenn ihr espresso verwendet dann
schmeckt der kuchen auch im abgang
leicht nach kaffee und falls ihr den
geschmack nicht so intensiv möchte dann
verwendet einfach einen milden kaffee
das verstärkt noch einmal den
schokoladengeschmack hier habe ich noch
mein vanille extra twitter zugegeben den
könnt ihr auch ganz einfach durch
vanillezucker ersetzen und anschließend
rühre ich noch die eier hinein und den
zucker
[Musik]
die schokoladenmasse gebe ich dann auf
den mürbeteig und hier ist es egal ob
der teig noch warm ist oder schon kalt
ihr seid also sehr flexibel
falls ihr wegen der optik nicht möchte
dass ein paar gläschen auf eurer tat zu
sehen sind dann nehmt eure springform
oder eben eure tat formen und lass dir
ein paar mal auf die arbeitsfläche
fallen anschließend geben wir die tat
wieder in den ofen bei 190 grad ober und
unterhitze wie schon gehabt für weitere
zwölf minuten nach dem backen lassen wir
die tat dann vollständig auskühlen und
lagern sie anschließend den kühlschrank
und vor dem verzehr habe ich sie hier
noch mit ein wenig kakao dekoriert ihr
könnt aber auch frische früchte nehmen
oder je nachdem was ihr grad da habt und
was sie am liebsten wirkt
ihr seht ihr noch den anschnitt meiner
tat und ich habe den dann anschließend
mit einem leckeren kaffee und frischer
sahne serviert
die tat ist wirklich sehr schokoladig
sehr lecker und sehr intensiv ich
persönlich liebe das weil ich ein
absoluter schoko fan bin und falls ihr
auch solche schokoladen fans seid oder
euren liebsten sogar eine freude damit
machen möchtet dann schaut gern mal
unten in die infobox da stehen sie immer
alle genauen mengenangaben
ansonsten bin ich sehr gespannt was er
zu sagen habt und auch euer feedback
wenn ich sie mal ausprobiert und dann
sage ich bis zum nächsten mal auf die
gis kitchen
[Musik]